your business is moving forward but
where is it going by simply exploring
the possibilities of the API economy
your company can easily discover a world
of possibilities new markets new revenue
streams and better customer satisfaction
taking the first step on your API
journey is important but you'll need a
plan to unlock your full potential
you'll want to move from an ad hoc
approach to a holistic view of your
company's api's you're seeing the whole
forests instead of just the trees with
api's you're securing and managing
access to your most valuable assets now
your company is growing and your 80 eyes
are maturing they're programmable and
value driven in this next phase you're
addressing consumer demands instead of
simply hoping it hits the mark the next
big step is when you start incorporating
api's into business models offerings and
channels you're letting your api's drive
your strategy instead of having the
strategy simply drive your api's at the
final stage you're able to enter whole
new markets with digital strategies that
reach beyond your four walls and engage
a larger audience
you've become an expert in the API
economy with the power of api's there's
no telling where your business can go
but it's easy to find out talk to IBM
about taking your business to the next
level in the API economy
[Music]